So like any other
theory of intelligence,
case-based reasoning
has some assumptions.
The first assumption is that there
are patterns to the problems that
agents encounter in the world.
The same kinds of problem tend
to reoccur, again and again.
A lot of science is about finding
patterns that are crowded in the world.
Physics finds patterns that
are crowded in the world that
are expressed by various kinds of laws,
like Newton's second law of motion.
Presumably, if you're going to build
a theory of intelligence, that theory
too will give an account of what kind of
patterns exist in the world that mind,
that intelligence, must encounter.
And case-based reasoning says,
one of the common patterns is
that the same kinds of problems
occur again, and again, and again.
So that's the first assumption.
The second assumption is that similar
problems often have similar solutions.
Here is a grid of a part of Long Island.
Here is a grid of part of Dallas, Texas.
Now if you look at the one in
Long Island, you can see that
if there are two problems which
are very close to each other,
they're likely to have
very similar solutions.
And the same is true for
the grid in Dallas.
Similarly, the second
assumption is not always valid.
Here is an example of it.
I'm sure all of you know
how to tie your shoelaces.
But imagine that you buy
a new pair of shoes, and
this new pair of shoes
have velcro straps.
Now the problem's very similar,
how to tighten your shoes, but
the solution is radically different.
>> So Ashoke, another example of
this that comes to mind, for me,
is the example of touch screens.
Some of the early touch screens could
only handle one touch at a time.
If you touched it with two fingers at
a time, it either wouldn't register, or
it'd only register one of the touches.
Current touchscreens, on smartphones and
tablet's that we use today, can handle
two or three or four fingers at a time.
The problem is very similar.
We're still touching the screen and
interacting with it with our fingers,
but the solution is actually very,
very different.
It uses a completely different kind
of technology, different material for
the screen, and
a different way of detecting where
the screen is being touched.
>> That's a good example, David.
So we have at least two examples
now where similar problems can have
quite different solutions.
Nevertheless, this assumption
is valid most of the time.
Most of the time,
two problems that are quite similar
will end up having two solutions
that are quite similar, as well.